let's talk to um
why don't we go to andrew from miami
andrew you're on the air hi david can
you hear me hi ken
hey so i was curious what your opinion
was of nancy pelosi recently
um investing 10 million dollars in
microsoft i didn't know that she did
what she bought 10 million dollars worth
of microsoft stock
correct around a month ago she invested
upwards of 10 million dollars in
microsoft stock and then shortly after
that
microsoft received a government contract
for a pretty large sum of money and then
the stock went up
you know there's a lot of stuff about
nancy pelosi
that is that is untrue and i want to be
careful because
there's a rumor that nancy pelosi is
worth 196 million
but it seems she's really only worth
five million dollars
so when you're telling me she invested
10 million i i just i haven't heard that
and i'm just unsure about that i i think
her husband
is quite wealthy i don't know because of
all of the incorrect
stuff i just don't know yeah her husband
just owns a major investment firm so he
has ties to wall street and then she
directly acts on legislation that would
affect
the stocks that she invests in yeah i
mean listen i've come out before and
i've said
um that it is too easy to violate the
stock act for members of the house and
senate there are real questions about
that being not nearly regulated enough
and i apply that to republicans as much
as democrats
specifically nancy investing 10 million
when as far as i know her net worth is
five i just i just don't know about that
gotcha yeah i mean just in light of her
recent comments as well after the shogun
uh trial it just seems like she's a
liability democrats and
yeah her comments about the chauvin
thing were for people who don't know she
said something like i want to thank
george floyd for sacrificing himself in
the name of
justice or whatever it's like whoa hold
on a second he didn't he didn't
sacrifice himself and that's really
strange language and it seems in
insanely incent that was just major faux
pas
i agree so it seems like she's a
liability to dems and it almost seems
like she wants republicans to win in the
midterms
i don't think she wants republicans to
win i just think she's making missteps
why would she want republicans to win
it would lengthen her ability to
continue fighting for corporations as
opposed to actually
people's interests nah nah that doesn't
really
i don't think so i i think nancy pelosi
certainly to some degree is
you know focused on herself but i have
no reason to think she wants republicans
to win
interesting thanks so much david all
right pleasure great to hear from you
uh okay let's see who else we can hear
from because
we really have been having some
beautiful phone calls today
um excellent excellent calls let's talk
to uh
lucas from hendersonville where is
hendersonville by the way
hey uh it's north of nashville oh okay
hendersonville
um tennessee very beautiful okay yes sir
thank you um my question to you is that
there is about
10 million illegal immigrants in the u.s
what steps should biden take to
[Music]
help accommodate those people into the
american society
that we have today well i think you have
to
kind of go in in stages and the first
thing
is daca has to be dealt with there has
to be a permanent solution on daca
it's hard for me to to lay out a full
policy
sequence because so much of it depends
on
if how and when daca is dealt with
um i do think that a clear path to
citizenship should be put in place
uh i mean i don't have any any unique
particular view on this
it's it's what uh you know i i like what
people like ro khanna have talked about
on immigration
and um you know congressman ruben
gallego and
and others uh just just kind of a just
reasonable
uh system where we're treating people
with respect
and we're understanding that the vast
majority
of undocumented immigrants are here
working paying into systems
and uh raising families etc yeah i don't
have anything
groundbreaking on that thank you
my pleasure uh appreciate the phone call
okay that is going to
close today's call session i
of course am deeply sorry that i was not
able to get to more people but we
we do operate with a time limit and we
are going to be back with many more
phone calls
very very soon we'll take a quick break
and be back with much more after this